hey everyone welcome back to another
video by simply da in today's video we
are going to discuss the top RPA
interview questions now if you are
looking to make a career in this field
and if you just browsing around for jobs
then you're in the right place
this video will absolutely help you
crack the next interview of yours so
without further ado let's begin the
first question is what is our P now
robotic process automation is the use of
software with artificial intelligence
and machine learning capabilities to
handle high-volume repetitive tasks that
previously required humans to perform
now some of these tasks could be
addressing queries making calculations
maintenance of records or even
performing transactions now RP is a form
of automation that basically sticks to
the front end of the system and carries
out tasks without having to move to the
back end now this is an essential
feature of RP
next up is mentioned a few applications
of rpm there are several applications to
mention a few we have open meals and
attachments fill in forms and move files
and folders follow if-then rules connect
a system API extract structure or data
from documents make complex calculations
monitor manual processes and learn how
to perform them read and write databases
scrape data from documents and even log
in to web enterprise applications
next question is mention a few
advantages of RBA firstly our period
users cost now by automating tasks the
cost saving of almost 30% can be
achieved through our PE our PA reduces
operational risks various companies
prefer to outsource busy work to
external parties now this comes with an
inherent risk of human errors and
inefficiency now our PA brings forth a
better solution and since work stays
in-house there's less operational risk
next up is quality and accuracy our PA
offers services to processes with a high
probability of human errors thereby
increasing accuracy robots are reliable
and consistent and don't complain when
expected to work tirelessly next up is
scalability with the help of our PA
companies can make adjustments based on
seasonality and can easily scale up or
down the operation as needed reduced
workload automating tasks like report
making can significantly reduce the
workload on the employee allowing them
to focus on other critical tasks
improved customer satisfaction
since accuracy is maintained an
operational risk is minimal customers
are provided with quality content lastly
we have improved business results since
all employees are focusing on activities
that add more value to the company
improved results in the business are
visible the next question is what are
some industries that can benefit from Rp
there are several industries and domains
that are currently benefiting from Rp to
mention a few
there's banking and finance IT
integration processes Human Resources
insurance agencies marketing and sales
and customer relationship management
moving on the next question what are RPE
tools now to meet the objectives of our
PA our paid tools are used they are the
software with the help of which one can
configure tasks and build BOTS taught to
meet them some of the popular ones in
the market today are UI path blue prism
automation anywhere work fusion and
record
moving on to next question explains the
working of RBA now the typical working
of our PA includes four crucial stages
the first stage is planning in this
stage the processes to be automated are
defined which includes identifying the
test objects finalizing the
implementation approach and defining a
clear roadmap with the RPE
implementation the next step is design
and development in this phase you start
developing the automation workflows as
per the Bri plan thirdly we have
deployment and testing this phase
typically includes the execution of the
bots any unexpected outages are to be
taken care of during the deployment to
ensure accurate functioning testing of
these bots for bugs and errors is
crucial lastly we have support and
maintenance providing constant support
helps in identifying and rectifying the
errors better
moving on to the next question what is
the difference between traditional
automation and RBA here is a simple
image for you to go on to talk about the
differences traditional automation
involves programming api's and
integration tools to integrate different
systems RP on the other hand
memens actions of the user at the user
interface level in the case of
traditional automation the developer
needs to have a good understanding of
the target system while in RPE as long
as the pod can exactly follow this test
the developer need not worry about the
underlying complexities
the next question is mentioned the types
of RPE now basically there are three
types of RP first up is unattended or
autonomous RP
now this is ideal for reducing work like
completing data processing tasks in the
background they do not require any human
intervention
now these bots can be launched at
specific intervals or they could be
bought initiated or they could be
triggered by some data input next up is
attended RP now these boss live on the
user's machine and are triggered by the
user they can be launched when embedded
on an employee's device or they can be
altered based on certain conditions or
they can be launched using the archaic
line tool lastly we have hybrid RP it
has a combination of attended and
autonomous BOTS
now these bots address front and back
office tasks in the enterprise
the next question is what are front and
back office pots now front office BOTS
are those whose deployment is totally in
the users control they require human
intervention they work from the same
desktop as that of the user
it can only be triggered by local
machines manually and cannot run
remotely when it comes to back of his
pots these pots can run on locked
machines from the orchestrator the user
may not be actively involved in it's
working and these boss can be triggered
remotely by servers
the next question is what are some
features of RPF first up is rich
analytical suite now our PA monitors and
manages automated functions from a
central console now this console can be
accessed from anywhere and offer basic
metrics on robots servers workflows and
more simple creation of bots our PA
tools allow quick creation of BOTS
effortlessly by capturing mouse clicks
and keystrokes with built-in screen
recorder components skip less automation
arpaia tools are code free and can
automate any application in any
department employees with less
programming skills can create BOTS
through gooeys security our PA tools
enable the configuration as well as
customization of encryption capabilities
for securing certain data types to
defend against the interruption of
network communication hosting and
deployment our PA systems can
automatically deploy bots in groups of
hundreds hence our PA can be installed
on desktops and deployed on servers to
access data for the protective tasks
debugging some RPE tools require to stop
running to rectify the errors while
other tools allow dynamic interaction
while debugging this is one of the most
powerful features of RPE moving on what
are the major differences between blue
prism and uipath moving on it the first
feature is trial version blue prism
offers a trial version it's available in
two options either on cloud or on the
local computer UI part on the other hand
offers free edition both trial and
license versions are available
moving on to base technologies
blue prism is completely based on
c-sharp uipath is based on SharePoint
keep Anna and elasticsearch moving on to
process designer blue prism allows you
to create design edit as well as test
business processes from the visual
business object but what exactly is a
VBO VBO can take the form of a set
coded functions which may be written in
vb.net or c-sharp dotnet uipath acts as
a visual process designer with friendly
developer options now a visual process
designer basically is a dashboard
consisting of various tools through
which a developer can define the
automation tasks
moving on to accessibility blue prism
allows only browser-based accessibility
UI part on the other hand provides
mobile and browser accessibility moving
on to robots blue prism offers back of
his automation only while uipath offers
both front and back office automation
the next crucial factor is a macro
recorder in case of blue prism a macro
recorder does not exist why in the case
of uipath it consists of a macro
recorder enabling faster process mapping
moving on
what is citrix automation any automation
solution built using a virtual desktop
or build to work in virtual desktops is
citrix automation it plays a major role
in small to corporate companies like BPO
and contact centers where applications
are being accessed remotely because of
security considerations next question is
what is UI path studio now you iPad
studio is basically a platform to create
the automation BOTS it encompasses
hundreds of activity templates and
ready-made components to drag-and-drop
UI paths to do consists of first up is
UI dashboard it offers a visual
dashboard with activities like send
email display message and so on it also
consists of different types of recorders
uipath studio offers various recorders
to record actions on multiple platforms
next up is logging and exception
handling it offers various options for
these tools such as debug open logs slow
step etc lastly it offers reusable
components here the user can create
usable components to publish them
together as libraries
moving on what our activities in uipath
the activities panel shows available
activities that can be added to the
current workflow users can use the
search box to find various activities
navigate through them using navigation
keys and press system activities pack
contains all the basic activities used
for creating automation projects these
activities enable the robots to
manipulate data tables by adding or
extracting information or directly
interact with directories and files on
your machine performing any action a
human user would also there are other
types of activities in the pack that aid
in the creation and execution of
automation projects themselves such as
logical operators and expressions
moving on what is a sequence in your eye
path the sequence is a simple linear
representation that flows from top to
bottom and defines which activities are
to be performed all right you can see a
simple example on your screen here so to
give you a detailed explanation let me
just navigate to your eye path and here
I can create a new sequence I go to new
click on sequence and let me call it
sequence as it is and say create alright
now a sequence is created so I wanted to
splay two messages so let's look for the
activity that is message box I drag and
drop it here and let me displaying hello
first and I drag another message box and
after that I drop it here and here let
me do that again alright and here I
display welcome all right so let's save
this and debug according to the logic
hello has to be displayed first and then
welcome right
so let's go ahead and see if it does
that all right you see a hello message
first followed by which you can see the
welcome message so this is what a
sequence is moving on to the next
question what is clipping in dy path
now scrapin can be done in two ways
first up is data splitting now this is a
technique with the help of edge
structured data can be extracted from
the web or any application and save to a
database or a spreadsheet or a dot CSV
file in the case of screen scraping it
is a process of collecting screen
display data from one application and
translating it so that another
application can display it
now you can see the two options on the
top of your user interface in UI path
moving on what are you i party robots
now uipath robots run the automation
that is created using the UI path studio
now there are two types of robots as
discussed earlier we have attended
robots how they work with you to speed
up the process next service desk
operation or help desk operations now it
is used in activities where human
involvement is key next up is unattended
robots now these operate without the
human touch maximizing cost and
performance benefits for any variety of
back office tasks next question what
does the UI path Orchestrator do now the
orchestrator is a centralized robot
management dashboard that you can easily
deploy secure and manage your UI path
robots at scale first you have to create
the bot the project is then published as
a process for further use once a process
is created it is assigned to a specific
robot to execute in an environment this
collectively constitutes a job all of
this is taken care of by the UI part of
the street our next question how is
exceptional handling achieved in uipath
exception handling is one of the error
handling methods in uipath the error
handling activity has four options first
up is reflow now using this activity a
robot throws an exception again
which was previously caught while
executing the workflow for this activity
we don't need to provide any specified
message secondly we have terminate
workflow now this is a mechanism
we can ask a robot to terminate rest
activities this activity is mostly used
when there is no data to process to use
this activity we may need to provide the
exception message which the bot may
login the arrowrock file which we can
refer to later third is through through
activity is a mechanism wherein if a bot
fails to execute a mentioned activity it
throws an error with a specified error
message to help us understand better
lastly we have try-catch now this
activity has three paths the try block
would be executed and if there was an
error it will be caught in the catch
section now after executing the try
block robot will execute the finally
block in any condition moving on what
our breakpoints in uipath grid points
are used to purposely pause the
debugging process on any activity that
made sugar execution issues you can
place and modify a breakpoint on any of
the activities as follows so from the
context menu you can right click on an
activity and select toggle breakpoint so
let me show you how that works so here
in my sequence I can just right click on
it and you are at you can see the toggle
breakpoint option you can go ahead and
click on that that is one of the methods
fault I can select the activity and
click on the breakpoints button on the
debug tab so let me show you here let me
select this
and in my debug tab I can click on
breakpoints and say probably breakpoint
that is another method and lastly I can
press f9 while the design activity is
being selected that's as simple as that
moving on to the next question
what is a macro recorder a macro
recorder allows you to record Mouse
events and keyboard activities to
generate automation scripts now the
activities are arranged based on the
sequence of actions being performed on
the screen right so this sequence is set
in your workflow which you can later use
it to playback the recorded action
moving on what are the user
in you iPod mention of you now user
events in you iPod specify the actions
performed due to the occurrence of
certain events right some of these
events could be click key press or
monitor Mouse or any monitor keyboard
etc so when it comes to unclick element
now this basically monitors all the
click events on a specified UI element
the mouse buttons left right and middle
are used for the click action by default
the left mouse button is selected on
pre-press element now this monitors
keyboard events on a specified UI
element special keys are supported and
you can select them from the activity
drop-down list this field supports only
strength and string variables on click
image this monitors the image defined by
the target UI element for Mouse input
and monitor Mouse
this monitors a specified Mouse key
combination system-wide event
moving on we have what are the different
activities performed by you iPod
we have core activities for automation
processes cognitive activities for
language translations credential
activities for enabling the addition or
deletion of credentials database
activity is basically used for executing
queries transactions etc we have excel
activities for automating ms excel tasks
ftp activities for performing functions
on the FTP server intelligent OCR
activities for digitization and scraping
we have meal activities for working with
IMAP pop3 SMTP Outlook we are PDF
activities for data extraction from PDF
Python activities for invoking Python
scripts and methods terminal activities
for retrieving data from the terminal we
have web activities for performing soap
and HTTP requests to any web api's and
their board activities for automating
activities in ms word so these are a few
you could mention moving on what does
the control room in automation anywhere
to the control room is a web-based
platform that controls automation
anywhere
alright the control room deals with user
management source control I mean the
code for the boss is managed by the
control room dashboard it gives complete
analytics and results of automation
anywhere pods and license management the
purchased licenses for automation
anywhere configured in the control room
now there are two types of licenses in
automation anywhere you have the device
license which allows you to create a bot
edit port and then run aboard and you
have the run license when the user can
only run the bot and cannot make any
changes
so this is what the control room does
moving on to the next question what is a
bot runner now a bot runner is the
machine where you run the board now you
could have multiple BOTS running in
parallel you only need the run license
to run the bolts the boss will report
back the execution logs pass/fail status
back to the control room moving on what
our task bots meta BOTS and IQ BOTS
so TAS BOTS basically are the bots at
automated rule-based
repetitive tasks in areas like
documentation administration HR claims
management etc moving on to meta BOTS
these bots are the automation building
blocks
it is designed in such a way that with
application changes or updates you need
to make minimal edits to this board any
changes made to the bot is easily
deflected lastly we have the IQ bots now
this is an advanced tool it can learn on
its own and perform a task according to
it IQ bots offered automation using
highly advanced cognitive technology
moving on is robotic process automation
similar to screens keeping or macros now
screen scraping mostly talks about the
old green screen applications maintain
ones where you basically capture the
screen you process it based on its
content and information that you have
when it comes to RPE it is more
intelligent more capable and much more
robust what it does if it connects to
the elements whether they have Windows
applications or Java applications does
not matter they connect all the elements
it does use screen scraping yes but it's
just a part of robotic process
automation they're not entirely the same
moving on what are thick and thin
clients a thick client is application
that requires certain attribute features
using our Patos example a computer or
calculator or Internet Explorer while a
thin client is the application that
never acquires the specific properties
while using the RP tools very simple the
next question is how does a chatbot
different from RPE
now a chatbot is basically a bot that is
programmed to chat with the user like a
human being would write well in case of
RTA it is a bot that is programmed to
automate a manual business process of
executing the task or any activity with
a business function alright so a chat
bot can be used as a medium to feed
input to the RT bot but it cannot
replicate the features of an RTA system
moving on to the final question can
selenium be used for rpm
well there are lots of test automation
tools in the market today like selenium
qtp and EPM these are good test
automation tools and note they cannot be
used for robotic process automation test
automation tools have a constraint they
require software in order to run but in
case of RTA it can be applied to
anything other than a product and mostly
RTA is used to automate business
processes so selenium for any test
automation tool for that matter
cannot be used for our tea
for that with that we come to the end of
this session
I hope these interview questions really
helped you if you have any queries let
us know in the comment section below
so thank you so much for being here keep
learning and stay tuned to simply on hi
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simple learn youtube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here